When we think of a Superhero we usually think
of their superpowers such as Superman’s
ability to fly or Spiderman’s skill to shoot
webbing. Every child has dreamed of having
these skills and being able to fight crime
but superpowers are not the only way a superhero
is defined as a superhero. If it was numerous
villains could be defined as a superhero too.
These unique personality traits, skills and
qualities are what make up superheroes and
sometimes the actors that play them possess
them too.
Subscribe to Screen Rant, as we introduce
you to Screen Rant’s list of ten Superhero
Actors Who Can Do Superhero Things.
Jennifer Garner as Elektra
Jennifer Garner showed her skills as the star
of the TV series Alias from 2001-2006 as CIA
Agent Sydney Bristow ​and as the assassin
Elektra Natchios in the 2003 film Daredevil
and the 2005 spin-off Elektra. She had a tremendous
work ethic, training, and plan to make her
roles believable but none more than her training
with Okinawan sai, Elektra’s usual weapon
of choice. These blades are dangerous but
Garner practiced daily while shooting to look
like a master on film and can still use them
to this day.
Jeremy Renner as Hawkeye
The bow-wielding superhero Hawkeye looks at
ease when shooting a bow in The Avengers films
for a reason. Renner trained under Olympic
archers to boost his skills to ensure he was
able to use a bow and arrow. Renner has said
that being a traditional straight-shooter
isn’t all that he needed to know while using
an arrow. The Avengers hero also pulverizes
his enemies by using his bow, as a blunt weapon
and spinning it like a baton too. Another
skill he has picked up along the way.
Nicolas Cage as Ghost Rider
Nicholas Cage’s Johnny Blaze is a stunt
motorcyclist who sold his soul to the Devil
and transformed into the vigilante Ghost Rider.
Even though his face didn’t into a skull
and catch on fire in real life, he was an
avid motorcyclist. He caused so much trouble
on his motorcycle that his insurance company
told him he wasn’t allowed to ride anymore.
So he eagerly looks for films that he gets
to ride a motorcycle in because he enjoys
it so much.
Ryan Reynolds as Deadpool
Ryan Reynold’s quick wit, dirty jokes and
sarcastic attitude are why fans are eager
to see him play the role of Deadpool again.
Luckily he has the same mindset as his superhero
character or we would never have seen his
2016 hit film. Reynolds is persistent! It
took him a decade to get the film Deadpool
made but he kept at it just like the revenge
his character perused in the film. He better
keep that persistence and give us a few more
sequels to Deadpool or we will be persistent
with bothering him for them.
Gal Gadot as Wonder Woman
Gal Gadot first portrayed Wonder Woman in
2016’s Batman Vs. Superman: Dawn of Justice
and she proved to the world she was flawless
for the role. Maybe this has to do with her
two-year stretch in the Israeli Defense Forces
where she was trained in weapons and combat
training. Wonder Woman fights against evil
just like Gadot was trained to. Next time
you see Gadot on screen battling a villain,
remember she can do that in real life too.
Mark Ruffalo as The Hulk
Dr. Bruce Banner becomes the Hulk in times
of stress and unleashes a destructive anger
known as the Hulk. In an interview withNew
York Daily News, Mark Ruffalo said that he
could relate to the Hulk because he had a
lot ofanger issuesin his 20s. Ruffalo
said, “There was a time if you came into
my apartment, there were pictures and posters
hanging in very odd places where they were
covering fist-holes through walls.” We are
glad he was able to use that anger in The
Avengers films and stop punching holes in
walls.
Hugh Jackman as Wolverine
Hugh Jackman is arguable the best actor to
play Wolverine and since he has been playing
the character for over 12 years we feel the
fans and studio agree. Not only does he prepare
with ruthless workouts but he also has trained
in martial arts; including samurai sword fighting.
Jackman’s skills as a martial artist make
his role more believable and give us another
reason to not want to mess with him in real
life. We will miss him as Wolverine.
Robert Downey Jr. as Ironman
Robert Downey Jr. is Tony Stark, and when
he dies his tombstone will most likely have
both names on it. He’s rich, has a fashion
flare, knows how to throw a party and he attributes
much of his success to his father. Still in
real-life he has hero instincts. When a woman
gashed her leg badly and onlookers stood shocked,
it was Downey who took charge. He helped control
the bleeding, kept her distracted and directed
people to call an ambulance and get her water.
He stayed until help arrived, ruining his
suit but helping a very grateful woman.
Taylor Kitsch as Gambit
The film, X-Men Origins: Wolverine is arguable
the weakest of the X-Men franchise but that
doesn’t have to do with co-star Taylor Kitsch.
Taylor Kitsch had the chance to play Gambit
in the X-Men Origins: Wolverine film and show
off some of his card playing tricks. He learned
how to trick shuffle and perform card tricks
just for the role. Sadly, we wont see any
more card tricks from him since he isn’t
cast in the upcoming Gambit film.
Tom Holland as Spiderman
Spiderman is one of the most athletic superheroes
in the MCU due to a bite from a radioactive
spider. The newly casted Spiderman, Tom Holland
showed off some of his skills in Captain America:
Civil War and fans were excited to see him
perform stunts. But not all of his stunts
were done with cables and CGI. Holland a trained
dancer has been training with stuntmen, Holland
Diaz for his upcoming Spiderman films and
recently showed a video of himself performing
a backflip while nailing the Spiderman pose.
What do you think of our video? Did we skip
over any other Superhero Actors Who Can Do
Superhero Things? Sound off in the comments
below and be sure to subscribe to our channel
for more fun videos! Thanks for watching!